I would be complex I would be cool
Taylor Swift is the man literally on
Thursday t-swift dropped the official
music video for her anthem the man and
it is good
[Music]
man the latest single off her hit album
lover addresses the double standards
between men and women and to really
drive home her point taylor straight-up
transformed herself into a man with the
help of some serious prosthetics food in
the work they wouldn't shake their heads
in question how much of this I deserve
yeah that that's Taylor anyway Taylor
the man gets priests at work rocks out
on a yacht gets high fives left and
right and seems to be welcomed with open
arms everywhere she I mean he goes
man
and in truth swifty fashion the video is
chock-full of Easter eggs like this
that's Taylor peeing on a wall at 13th
Street Station a nod to her favorite
number around that station sign we see
graffiti art with the names of Taylor's
past albums from fearless to red to
reputation then there's that sign that
reads missing if found returned to
Taylor Swift fans were quick to weigh in
speculating that it's a reference to
Taylor's battle for the rights to her
own music I just think that I think that
artists deserve to own their work I just
feel very passionately about that then
there's that yeah that's a no scooters
allowed sign which i think is pretty
safe to say is a nod to her feud with
scooter broad hard to miss read that one
people oh and just check out that poster
for mr. Americana starring Taylor Swift
a twist on the singer's Netflix
documentary Miss Americana you know my
entire moral code as a kid and now is a
need to be thought of as good it was all
I wrote about it was all I wanted it was
the complete and total belief system but
I subscribed to as a kid of course it
wouldn't be a Taylor Swift video without
a few surprise cameos
when Taylor fights with an umpire on the
tennis court that UMP is Taylor's dad
Scott Swift hey just checking was that
last take more what you had in mind
pretty good could you try to be sexier
maybe more likeable this time yeah at
the end of the video we finally hear the
man speak okay
okay no problem if that voice sounds
familiar it's because Dwayne Johnson
lent his vocals for the part I take
credit and get this guy's Taylor wasn't
just acting she actually did direct to
this video huh it's it's just
unbelievable oh and if you thought we
covered all the classic Taylor hidden
meaning stuff you were wrong
stay with me on this one Taylor dropped
the video on February 27th On February
27th 1992 the Supreme Court upheld the
19th amendment the voting rights for
women
Taylor referenced the number 19 when she
teased the music video earlier this week
on Twitter writing there are 19 hands in
the hallway but only two days until the
man music video right and before t-swift
released the video she did a little Q&A
on YouTube when one fan asked who would
be playing the man Taylor simply
responded a boss yes Queen a boss indeed
I am so here for this music video but
not gonna lie to you guys all that fake
facial hair is making me feel secondhand
itchy anyone else just me okay well you
know you can count on et to bring you
all the latest on Taylor so make sure to
stay locked right here until next time
I'm Hallie Stevens I'll see you soon
[Music]